It's basically
material
route 60 12 of us were like,
we just put your house in perfect order before you criticize the world.
It's a consequence that the discussion surrounded is a conference,
a problem that I be trying to for a very long time.
And so to fix it teams to clearly formulated girl,
which is actually the most difficult,
harder.
Once you,
once you can formulate the problem,
it's fairly easy for lay on possibilities,
but it clearly formulate the problem is very difficult.
It doesn't mean it's necessarily easy.
So,
so to solve the problems,
to formulate the drug,
but also then to
articulate it deeply enough so that it principal,
it might go away.
You know,
if you have an argument with someone in your family,
your wife or your husband or the sibling,
and there's real conflict around it.
If you on foot properly and be walked through it,
then you don't have to have to fight,
right?
Because you,
you've negotiated a settlement problem disappears.
And that's actually how you normally,
if you understand something,
is that the problem isn't here.
That takes care principle.
And so the problem that I want to talk to you about tonight is I probably
wouldn't make me from specific,
I spent a lot of time thinking about totalitarianism [inaudible].
We're very interested in both of those topics interested in ideological
possession,
but I'm more interested in something that's the most extreme area.
The larger
the proclivity of people to use.
Unbelievably brutal means.
I've been forcing adherence to the ideology because eating all that in itself is
a mystery.
Why people believe things that they do,
but why they're willing to use,
why they're willing to commit atrocities in service of those ideologies.
It's a much deeper history and one of the stories that really affected me when I
was studying happened in Nazi Germany,
indigo like counts the Soviet Union because those are the two forms of master
trust.
Let's say that
deeply.
What is the story that never really left my imagination?
This was a story or something that was inflicted upon my prisoner
in Auschwitz during the time of the Nazi concentration camps.
Do you understand that?
Something like that,
you kind of have to put yourself to the area,
you know,
and that's an uncomfortable thing to do for all sorts of reasons.
You can put yourself there as big thing,
which is actually more comforting in some sense.
I mean it's hot but it's comforting.
But your option is basically victim or perpetrator,
right?
Think a situation like that.
I think it's easier for people to imagine themselves as addicting.
It's not that that's easy cause it's not,
it's a paragraph into two bootcamp,
but it's nowhere near as error
generally speaking as it is to hazard your cell phone perpetrator.
And you might not be willing to do that.
But that's actually a mistake because unless you're willing to think that the
sorts of people who perpetrated the catastrophes of Nazi Germany and the Stella
was Soviet Union,
I was China,
Cambodia,
et Cetera,
without we Annie,
including North Korea,
including now and then as the way that this neighbor.
And that means that the people who do it a different species that you are the
same and I don't really think that we're ever going to be able to stop back
short claim so it can be stopped and that better be the case without reading
those situations as if we're the perpetrators and that's a terrible thing to do,
but they don't think that there's any way situations without understanding that.
One of the things I often encourage my students to understanding,
we never contemplating history and reading history is that they stopped creating
history like if something happened in the past and start hurting like it's an
autobiography because it's much more effective.
Your historical creature,
when you read about history,
when you read history,
you are greeting now you might not know that because you're not every form of
human.
You could be like your whatever particular form you joke right here is now about
you have the potential within the a multiplicity of the,
I think it was Alexander Pope who said,
if I remember correctly and nothing human is foreign to me that's a hell of a
statement on the up shop.
It's really quite something cause there's obviously the great people down
inside.
It's really something to,
and so to develop a detailed self understanding is to develop an understanding
that enables you to,
to,
to understand what your affiliation with the Nazi camp guards.
And that's a very unpleasant thing.
So the situation with
second was people were brought there often in Cali cars often in either freezing
weather or in very hot water and they're all crammed together in cattle are
standing mostly as many people as it possibly can be crammed in.
And like that man,
there's many of them died on the way there.
They Pete of sauce tumor,
they froze to death if they were on the outer sides of the car or they suffocate
they yard.
So it's all,
it's very difficult to lens and how terrible that must have baby.
And then of course they bribed accounts and they were sorted it to people who
from whom some useful labor might conceivably be extracted or those who were
doing a relatively immediate death.
And then that's all bad know for sure.
I mean these people were initiated to begin with and then they were separated
under brutal conditions from their,
from their life and so from their past and the present and the future.
Absolutely traumatizing.
The families were destroyed,
everything was taken away from them.
They were treated as badly as animals are treated when they're treated badly and
then,
and they were brought to these accounts and the counselor cute places that they
were the size of small cities and you think of camp,
don't think of the city that review.
That's what they were.
And that was enough for the people who have admin accounts,
you know,
which is really something because you think that would be enough no matter how
wrong you were motivated by,
you might think that that would do the trick in all fundamentally they really
didn't do the trick.
You know there,
there was a sign over Auschwitz,
which is so Alaskan brought back decided that existed in many,
in many variants.
I,
if there was only one of the,
and I can't say the German,
it's something like Arabic connect to free material is lacking but it needs
workable second free.
That was the model of camp.
That's awesome.
Really stuck in my mind because it was a joke but it's actually a chill,
it's really something to think of a mind that would conceptualize thousand Jill
and could have been that sort of place.
Work rule,
second free account that was designed to work people to death and not even for
the work that they do.
You know,
because if the Nazis would've had any sense and say we can be motivated by what
they say thing with,
again we're motivated by,
they would have said the caps off the entrepreneur humane manner.
They would abuse you people.
They put in the counts as slaves to further the war effort and they might avoid
the war,
but that isn't what they did.
They brought Paul to Jews and the Gypsies and all the other people.
They decided worth worth having around each of the couch.
So you just basically work the point to see the death.
And the reason for that was because that was one way you could make the depth.
The worst it could be,
you know,
because they usually work as a punishment.
You know,
if you work,
you killed it anymore.
Soldiered isn't talked about this in the gulag.
He was there,
he said,
well at least,
but he was playing breaks as a prisoner.
He had the gradis gratification,
let's say if you need to build a straight wall of bricks,
right?
There was something about productive labor.
He's engaged in productive labor or the name we need to find at least see some
tiny shred of useful meaning in this absolutely dismal,
wretched earner,
a circumstance.
But there were people who were running the camps like Auschwitz,
who wanted to take,
even now the way it worse than that,
invert it.
And so one of the things that the count cards used to do to the new prisoners
was to have them pick up wet socks,
wet 100 pounds,
100 pounds,
socks went salt,
and then carry them on their backs.
And remember I already told you that these people had already been through from
one side of the account to the other at.
That wasn't enough either.
Even though there was no reason to move the soul and it was only a demonstration
of power levels with demonstration of the sub absolute subjugation of the
prisoners to this,
what would you call it?
Universal human necessity for work.
We have to work for it.
It's one of the curses God blazoned on us at the end of the story about me.
People have deployed and,
and you can find meaning in that you can invert,
it becomes a torture and you do that by making it pointless if an and office
appointments.
So we carry that red sock,
sacrifice salt from one side of the camp out was obviously a parody of work and
that was what the joke referred to this parody and work,
but that wasn't enough either.
They had to carry it back.
Right.
You think there's a real artist in math,
right?
The same artists that came up with a joke.
There's something about that that system,
it's almost unmeasurable,
dark and that would be trying to understand that.
Why is that exactly?
It's not like it's a question.
It's gone up vote.
Although it's a question that people don't like to ask or answer,
you know,
in your country and Anaheim,
um,
we have this spectacle of the mass murder.
It's a competitive game that often young men played.
You know,
I call it a game for good reasons and competitive and for good reason that the
mass members,
school shooters,
those sorts of people,
they keep track of each other.
Now they try to up the ante.
Each tap,
the most egregious attacker is probably the one at Sandy Hook,
I would say.
Or the elementary school kids were killed because that brings up another level
of Mres,
right?
It's like,
why didn't you go after it?
You get this
if you're all tour for her Revengeance why not punish the guilty and answer
that?
Because it's more effective to punish the innocent because it's more of a
violation.
It's a greater violation of good,
let's say it,
since it's a more evil laugh,
it's more vegetable active.
You know,
perhaps the most data sets this,
it might be elementary school children,
especially ones that you don't know.
And so the killer of the sandy hook killer,
something like he had me think this through.
Right?
And that's another thing to consider.
You don't get to the point where you do something like that on a win or to take
months,
or even years of dark fantasizing before you get to that point.
And,
and you can go places that are hard to get imaginable.
When you allow yourself to be taken over by the kind of spirit that produces
that kind of fantasy.
Right.
Then where do you go as a place where you think that bringing them a deadly
weapon into an elementary school and deliberately targeting innocent children is
actually up a goal that's reasonable to pursue.